[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
yeah
No
okay why don't we go ahead and get
started
nice big crowd we're all excited for
Rory not to put any pressure on her
anyways as probably just about everyone
here knows today is the dissertation
defense by Rory and she's been a fixture
around the department for a while but
it's now about to make a next step in
her career and so she will present
defense of the work that she has done in
her dissertation and then we'll have
open for public questions and then as
everyone knows the audience will be
excused her committee will remain behind
and ask some additional questions and
then she'll be excused and then they'll
decide whether she successfully defended
her thesis or dissertation
most of you know Rory she originally
hails from Alaska and she did her
undergraduate work here at University of
Portland as a math major and now has
been in our ph.d program in the
bioinformatics and computational biology
track for the last several years and so
I will let her go forward thank you Bill
for the nice introduction can everyone
hear me okay in the back okay so I'm
very excited to be here today and to
share my dissertation work with you so
thank you for being here okay so let's
get started we often talk about
precision cancer treatment or precision
oncology and when we say this what we
mean is the vision that we can match
each cancer patient with the best drug
for them so I'd like to go through a
couple examples of what this might
actually look like so in the top panel
what we have is something called an
umbrella trial so this is a clinical
trial where we have a group of patients
and we have
genetic sequencing sequencing
information and then we actually use
that genetic information to group the
patients into different subgroups and
then each subgroup gets a different drug
so you can see then that we've matched
each patient with the best drug for them
so another example is called predictive
modeling so this is very near and dear
to those of us on the computational side
here the idea is that with all that rich
genetic information about a cohort a
cohort of patients we can actually
computationally model or it's called in
silico modeling to figure out beforehand
who's going to respond to a drug or who
might not respond to a drugs also
predicting on adverse effects as well so
one of my favorite examples is called
repurposing so this is more of a drug
centric perspective so thinking about
how the drug actually works in the arm
across the top here we have the drug
acting through one mechanism of action
and we use that to treat a group of
people but if we know another mechanism
of action how that for how that drug
works then we may actually be able to
treat a whole second group of people
potentially with a different disease
entirely and then lastly because this is
very relevant for designing cancer
treatment and sir treatments we have a
combination drug design so now imagine
for one patient we're looking at their
genetic information and we actually see
that they have multiple genetic
aberrations and so they might need two
or more drugs to actually design the
best treatment for them so this is the
vision and this is where we'd like to go
but we're definitely not there yet
there's a lot of barriers that we face
in to making this a reality
both on the research side and in the
clinic side so I'd like to go through
basically the questions that I have
asked in my research and give you kind
of a roadmap through my work and I'm in
the problem space that I work on in this
area so it starts with how our drugs
work so we need to know how our drugs
actually act in order to be able to
predict what they're going to do so
we're going to be talking a lot about
drugs and targets or the entities that
drugs actually bind with and we need to
know not just how our drugs interact
with their intended targets
but also they're off targets or what we
didn't intend to hit then we're going to
scale up a little bit and think about
putting these targets into greater
biological context so all these
molecular entities work together in
biochemical pathways inside of ourselves
and so now we want to be thinking about
how the drugs interact with these on
pathways so that's thinking about what
does our druggable space look like for a
set of drugs and especially thinking
about what the coverage of the coverage
for our drugs is in a disease or cancer
specific manner now that we've moved
into the pathways we really want to make
sure we want to stop and assess is this
unit appropriate for assessing drug
response that's our endpoint that we
care about is the patient actually
responding to the drug and moving a
little bit beyond that we're going to
talk about some modeling work to think
about actually what happens to these
biochemical pathways inside these cells
and thinking about the impact of genomic
perturbation so when we have mutations
what's the effect on those functional
pathways and then in parallel also going
to be thinking about the impact of drug
perturbation so kind of these two arms
going down both sides and then we're
going to close with bringing it together
to think about what do we still need to
bring these two aspects of the modeling
together so that we can go forward with
this vision of actually matching
patients based on their mutation
information with the best drug for them
so we're gonna start off talking a
little bit about drugs so many of you
might have heard this before but the
dirty little secret about drugs is that
we don't know how they work actually we
have mechanistic information for very
few of our drugs so just to kind of set
this up I want to talk about some
terminology so when we say primary or
intended target we're referring to the
entity or the receptor in a Cell that
the drug molecules actually bind to
that's how the drugs work and exert
their action we also often say secondary
or off targets so this is everything
else that the drug binds to and often
when we say primary it's talking
about a target that's been implicated in
a disease so maybe what that drug was
first designed for but drugs are what we
call it they exhibit poly pharmacology
so they interact with many targets and
as you can see from this diagram things
have now started to get much more
complicated this drug shows that it
interacts with three different targets
and what the arrows are representing is
our confidence or our knowledge about
those targets so for instance the yellow
target has a solid line and so that
might be that we know this drug binds to
this target but then the blue and the
green ones have dashed lines and so
we're not sure maybe only a couple
studies have been conducted so there's a
degree of uncertainty about that so from
a research standpoint it becomes really
important that we have information for
how our drugs work across all these
targets but we face a problem and that
when we go out into the public
literature or into the public domain the
information is very convoluted for drug
target interactions and oftentimes
different resources will report
different targets for the same drugs so
if you are trying to pull this
information together it puts a very big
burden on you to sort through this
information every time you have a
question about how that drug works so in
the first aim of my work I've gone out
and aggregated drug target interaction
data for about a hundred and forty
cancer approved drugs so for these drugs
I've pulled together information from
four different databases that are all
publicly available that means they're
free for any of us to use and put that
all into a database so this is called
the cancer target home right because for
all those drugs that houses the target
interactions and what's unique about the
cancer target home is that it's actually
paired with an evidence framework so
what that means is for every drug target
interaction you look up you can actually
ask the question of how confident are we
what's the supporting evidence behind it
so on the right-hand side here I'm
showing the evidence levels that we
assigned to drug target information so
level one means that we found it in a
database level two means that when we
pulled it from the database we also had
a literature reference so there's been
an article
published somewhere describing that
interaction and then level three means
we have that information but then we
also have a binding assay value so that
means that we have the record reported
of an experimental binding assay that
actually tested that drug and target
binding so you can imagine that this
becomes very important when you go to
see what targets your drugs binds to
because you'd like to know what the
strength of evidence is supporting that
interaction and so having all this
information together allows us to
actually start to prioritize or we get
through the weeds and all of this data
so we found very nicely that it actually
is important to aggregate from multiple
resources so this plot is just showing
that the aggregation improves our
coverage so the first four bars in each
plot are showing you the coverage we get
for the drugs for the targets they bind
to and the unique interactions and
what's important here is the dark blue
bar which you can see is higher just a
little bit for the drugs quite a bit for
the targets and the ad interactions
showing that each of these databases
actually contains different information
and when we pull it all together we get
the best picture when we look at the
breakdown of our coverage by evidence
level the things start to get a little
more interesting so starting with the
yellow bar is where we actually allow
for all interactions so any drug target
information supported by any evidence of
level and then within each panel as you
go to the right and you get to the
darker blue we're required
requiring stronger and stronger evidence
so so as we get to the blue bar
we're actually requiring that we have a
binding assay reported and then as it
gets darker we're saying that that
binding assay value has to be lower and
what that reflects is that there's a
stronger binding relationship between
the drug and the target and so just to
tell you these levels a little bit so
the the light blue is at 10,000 nano
molar for the binding assays so that's a
general cutoff we use to say that there
might be activity between this drug and
this target but then all the way to the
darkest blue here is down to a
nanomolar and that's really the space we
need to be in to think about whether
these drug target interactions might be
relevant for the human body
right so not just activity but whether
it's potentially going to be clinically
relevant okay so we started out looking
talking about an example of thinking
about our intended targets right so the
drug imatinib or Gleevec is a
breakthrough targeted therapy for
chronic myeloid leukemia so it was
really a game changer for that disease
and it's one of the best examples we
have of having a very very strong
primary target so it exerts its action
through the target able one which is
shown in purple here so we can see it up
in the top left corner each the way this
plot works is each of these panels is
showing you a different type of binding
assay value so there's four different
types here they're just four different
ways of getting at that binding activity
and what's important here is that we
know a mat and it binds to able one and
so we'd like to be able to see in all
this data that we collected is that
showing up and sure enough we can see
that that dark purple shows up in all
four lines of evidence and it's very
very far to the left so it is a very
very low or very strong binding assay
value so I will note that there are
additional targets that this drug binds
to you can see all the other colors each
color is one target so we can see PDGF
beta and pdgfr alpha as well as DDR one
these are also targets that this drug
binds to but people want to support it
across all four binding assay types so
now we're starting to see how it's
really important to have all this type
of information actually behind the drug
target interaction to to get more
detailed information so I also mentioned
so this idea of these secondary are
these off targets so this is here we are
now with the blue and the green and just
to illustrate why this is so important
that we keep this on our radar I'd like
to show another example so this drug
bandit and
here I'm showing you the same range of
binding assay values that we saw before
but now it has 26 different targets that
it binds to so that's a lot of off
targeting and we'd potentially really
like to know that when we're thinking
about using this drug and so
interestingly here - so in the top panel
you see a lot of blue bars for EGFR but
we also see Abel one kit rip-queue - and
ret and then in the second panel we're
seeing a lot of red bars that's kdr we
do see a one bar for EGFR flat one and
Sirk and what I'd like to note here is
that in this case for this drug the
panels are actually providing us with
different information so if you were
just to look at the top panel or just to
look at this bottom panel you would have
a very different view of the targets
that this drug interacts with and so and
this shows us that it's really important
again to have all that information
because if we take just a limited view
we're not going to have the full
targeting profile okay so now we're
gonna scale up a little bit to start
think about those biochemical pathways
and druggable space so what I'm showing
here is the orange diamonds are drugs
and they're interacting with a
biochemical pathway which is called pre
knotch transcription and translation
it's in the yellow there so each node
here is one pathway and as we go up
farther they're hierarchical
relationships so child to parent
pathways so the orange the drugs are
interacting with this pathway through
the targets within the pathway and to
introduce some terminology here light
pathway is one is a pathway that the
drug interacts with potentially whereas
a dark pathway shown in blue is one
where the drug does not interact with
any targets so in this case these two
drugs are arsenic trioxide and been
blasting and you can see the targets
they're interacting with our Jun and CC
and d1 and importantly they're supported
by level 2 evidence so that means we
actually don't have reported binding
assay values for them and if we were to
work
why're that rigor of information then we
would have all of these pathways go dark
and potentially not be druggable just to
put this into bigger context so we were
in that little square but these pathways
are nested and hierarchical so they're
all involved in higher order processes
and this is just to kind of give you a
big picture of that and so when we're
thinking about mapping the drugs to
these pathways using this light and dark
framework it really gives us an idea of
the scope of our current drugs
especially when we start to think about
whether patients have mutations in these
pathways if we could even get at those
pathways with our current drugs so using
a total of 2008 characterized pathways
from the database react dome when we use
all the cancer drug information we have
about 60% of the pathways are light or
potentially druggable so that starts to
give you an idea of what we might
actually be able to do with that set of
drugs as we require a more and more
strict evidence so coming down to level
3 were down to only 50 percent of the
pathways and requiring under that 100
nanomolar so remember where we're
starting to be clinically relevant we're
at about a third of pathways are
potentially light so really the picture
would look something like this where
most of the pathways are still dark and
about a third of them are potentially
druggable with our fda-approved cancer
drugs so this becomes important when
we're thinking about a cancer specific
or disease relevance in a disease
relevant manner so this is work from the
head and neck squamous cell carcinoma
group so the P is R dr. McQueen E and
dr. coulis Martin and I've been working
with this group during my time here and
this analysis is by Gabby Juno and
looking at enriched pathways so that
means pathways that are very important
specifically for this type of cancer
we found Gabby found that 60% of those
are dark to current drugs and 40% are
potentially alight so you can see how we
can really start to power power the use
of cancer target ohm in
a disease specific manner here so I'm
gonna switch a little bit because and
give you some background about my second
aim but now we're going to be moving
into thinking about really connecting
this pathway approach to drug response
so to give you some backward background
in my second aim I've had the
opportunity to work with data from the
beat AML consortium so this is a really
big effort at treating a big consortium
for understanding the disease acute
myeloid leukemia and so over the last
several years this effort has collected
over 900 samples from patients with AML
and what's really unique about this this
huge effort is that they have collected
both the genomic information so we have
RNA expression and whole exome
sequencing but they're also conducting
functional assays so drug screens to
actually see if the patient samples how
they respond to different different
cancer drugs and so a big key part of
this work is to put these different
types of data together and modeling and
prioritization and actually nominate
targets for future work and then moving
into clinical trials to find new
therapies for patients with AML so a
little bit about this disease so it's a
type of blood cancer it's seen very
little progress in the last 40 years in
terms of treatment one of the things
about AML that makes it very challenging
is that the patients from a genomic
perspective can look very very different
so in this inset here what I'm showing
is the significantly mutated genes that
come up in this disease and what you can
see here is basically this
characterization of what we call the
long tail and cancer or on the left side
we have some genes that we see in many
samples or many patients with AML but
then very quickly there's a lot of genes
which only some people have and so this
can make it very difficult when we're
thinking about subgrouping or figuring
out the best treatment this
heterogeneity
we call it okay so with that in mind
I've been working I've had the
opportunity to work with about 200
patient samples for dana de novo AML so
that means that the AML has arised
for the first time rather than being
related to another treatment for
instance I'm using paired tumor normal
samples and the mutation data and just
to give us some perspectives when we're
thinking about mapping these mutations
to pathways
there's two different takes that we can
think about so in the top panel I'm
showing pathway burden by gene so here
we're taking those pathways that we
talked about and we're saying what's the
burden or the mutational load when we
map mutations to that pathway so you can
see in the schematic there's both a
yellow and a blue know that we're seeing
a mutation in that pathway then we ask
the question basically if there's more
mutations in that pathway more genes
mutated than we would expect at random
so is it very interesting that this
pathway and is this pathway very
important but an alternative way to look
at it this is to actually think about
pathway burden by cohort where instead
of mapping the genes we think about the
number of samples that have an
alteration in the pathway and this
allows us a slightly different take and
importantly we can think about the
example where we might have a small
number of genes affected in the pathway
and that wouldn't necessarily be enough
to show up in the first approach but if
there's a lot of samples with those
small number of genes we really want to
get at that information so this is the
results of looking at the enrichment
from the first perspective so this is
basically asking the question of which
pathways have more genes mutated than we
would expect at random for this disease
AML and so there's three pathways that
came up chromatin organization collagen
biosynthesis and RNA
polymerase three transcription and
they're just shown in red to show that
they passed the statistical significance
here so to compare this to the other
perspective we can also think about the
pathway burden by cohort and so here we
see a lot more pathways that are showing
up really highlighting the importance of
taking a different perspective for that
pathway burden so here there's about
forty six pathways that have a large
number of samples that all have
alterations in the pathway and many of
them make a lot of sense for what we
know about and also signaling by b-cell
receptor
we've got signaling by s CF kit and
other interleukin signaling which is
where flip three is home which is a very
important gene and AML so this tells us
we're now we're thinking about
mutational burden for pathways but we
really want to bring that home and
connect it to actual drug response so
when we assess whether there is a
relationship between having mutations in
a certain pathway and actual drug
response we find that there is in many
cases so this is what's called a volcano
plot and each one of the circles that
you see represents a single test between
a drug and a pathway and so what we did
is for our cohort of samples we
basically have sub split them into two
groups for each of these tests where you
say if they have a mutation in the
pathway versus if they don't and is
there a difference in their drug
response so one of the big circles at
the top here is sunitinib and other
interleukin signaling so that's where
flipped three is and foot three
interacts with a sunitinib so this was
like a really great positive control we
have a lot of the flip three pathways
and flip three inhibitors showing up
here so and I should have said this but
as we get to the top of the graph the
interactions are more significant and
then as you go to the left we're looking
at interactions that are sensitive so
meaning when you have a mutation in that
pathway you have a better response to
that
on the right we have resistant
interactions so having a mutation that
pathway means you're actually less
responsive to the drug and to show you
an example of one of these a little bit
more in-depth to help make it clear so
this is just one of those circles that
we saw in the last plot and we're kind
of basically zoom in a little further so
each dot here is now a sample on the
left side we have all the samples where
they don't have mutations in this
pathway which is signaling by SCF kit
and on the right we have all the samples
where they do have a mutation in the
pathway and so there's actually a
significant difference between these two
box plots and if we look at all the
samples where they do have mutations and
SCF kit we can see that they all have
different genes mutated in this pathway
so this approach of looking at the
pathway view actually allows us to
groups samples and aggregate across many
different genes that are mutated and
then I just like to call out that the in
blue we have n rafts mutated and then we
also have chaos and ptpn11 is in purple
so there's really a whole spectrum of
genes that are driving that are in this
pathway and potentially driving this
resistant interaction because these are
samples that are showing higher AUC or
less response to this drug which is NVP
ADW 742 it's an inhibitor so so we see
these genes and so the next question is
really to ask if this gave us more
information than looking at individual
relationships between the gene and the
drug so this is also a volcano plot it's
a little bit different because it's just
assessing the difference between each
gene and the drug response and so if we
come into the right corner and blue here
what you can see is that n r s and K
rafts were both the genes that came up
as being associated with resistance to
this inhibitor and so those were two
that we saw in our pathway but in our
previous slide we also saw many
additional genes that are
showing up as individually associated
with this inhibitor and then I'll just
say that this is work by dr. Beth walnut
dr. McQueen II and also Daniel Bottomly
as part of the zone for the beat AML
work so in the inset that was the
boxplot that we just looked at so that
interaction between the pathway and the
inhibitor and that's what we get when we
just basically map mutations to the
pathway and we ask is the pathway
mutated or not but now we won't really
want to dig in a little deeper and ask
how do mutations in the pathway right we
saw those different different genes are
mutated how do they actually affect drug
response differently and so we need to
think about how these genes might be
having different effects and a pathway
and so we're gonna start to go into
pathway impact and the modeling work
that I've done for this and just as a
quick intro I'll be using a type of
modeling called probabilistic graphical
models and these very nicely allow us to
convert those biochemical pathways so
represent them as mathematical models
and we have a suite of algorithms called
message-passing algorithms that allow us
to basically impact or perturb one node
in the graph and propagate that impact
elsewhere and this allows us to actually
assess impact of mutations across the
pathway so a little bit over an overview
we're going to think of the null pathway
model or no perturbation so that's just
how that biochemical pathway functions
as it is and then on the left hand side
we're going to think about adding the
perturbation of a mutation so when we
have mutations in our genes how does
that affect how that pathway would
normally function and then on the right
hand side we have the pathway model with
drug perturbation so thinking about when
drugs bind to targets within that
pathway what is the resulting
perturbation in that case okay so each
pathway in reactants with each of those
biochemical processes is represented as
what
is called a factor graph so that's shown
here factor graphs have two types of
nodes so the circle nodes where you see
X 1 and X 2 are called variable nodes
they each represent one of the entities
in the pathway variable nodes can have 2
states 0 or 1 and they can be not
impacted or impacted and what's
important about the type of modeling
we're doing is that each of those states
actually is associated with a
probability so where we're really
thinking about the probability that X 1
is impacted or not impacted and then the
second type of node in this graph is
shown as the squares so FA FB and FC and
those are factored functions that
basically describe the relationship
between nodes so if X 1 is very impacted
will X 2 be impacted so the way this
works is that we have some observed
entities so these are places in the path
of entities in the pathway and where we
actually see mutations in the genes so
now it's shown in blue and then we have
this message passing algorithm that
actually allows us to propagate the
impact through the graph to the
neighbors so that we can see that impact
on the rest of the pathway and then for
each entity in the graph we're actually
quantifying you can think of it as let
the final probability of whether it's
going to be in the 0 or the 1 state and
that's just known as the entity beliefs
and we repeat this process many times
until we basically arrive at one not
changing belief or that's also called
convergence for each entity so we're
running this for each sample gets their
mutations loaded onto the pathways and
then we're looking at the impacted
pathways per sample so on the right side
is what I showed you with the observed
mutations and then I just wanted to be
kind of clear about then we can actually
compare it to what we get from running
the pathway model without any mutation
information so comparing mutation to
null and this allows us for
entity to actually come up with a log
odds ratio so basically just what I'm
showing here is x1 we see what we get
for the belief and the mutated state and
we're going to compare it back to the
probabilities that we had in the null
state and then we do this for each
entity in the graph right so that we
know where we stand and then at the end
for the whole pathway we're actually
going to summarize the pathway impact
using the average of the log odds across
these entities so here's the result of
the mutation impacted pathways for the
AML a de novo samples so for 187 samples
we are looking at so what you can see
here is each circle is one pathway that
the modeling says is very impacted based
on mutations that we see for the cohort
so up at the top you can see neutrophils
degranulation actually has 60 samples
that are impacted for this pathway and
we also see signaling by type 1 i GF 1
are generic transcription other
interleukin signaling is where flit 3 is
so that's one that we would expect to
see for AML and then also point out this
one here G alpha Q signaling events
which is involved in GPC are signaling
because we're going to come back to this
pathway as it has a very very high
impact compared to other pathways much
farther out here so remember at the
beginning we talked about the parallel
approaches so we're also going to be
running this modeling for the drug
perturbation so now instead of the blue
mutations that I showed you
we're actually thinking about the drug
binding to the target and propagating
the effect through the graph after the
drug binds and so very nicely here we
actually have all this cancer target and
binding information to use from the
first aim and so when we require level 3
or binding assay evidence we can
actually use the strength of the binding
assay to quantify the effect of that
we're having of the drug binding on the
target so this is the similar to the
graph we saw before only now
showing drug impacted pathways so there
were a total of 32 drugs that we had in
the BA ml drug screen and we also have
information on them in cancer target ohm
and so these are the impacted pathways
for that set of drugs a lot of them are
kinase inhibitors and what we can see is
that there's the raft map kinase cascade
and GF signaling signaling by erbb2 SEF
kit which we talked about and ret and so
this gives us a perspective of the
pathways that are affected by drugs now
so that second arm and then also here's
our G alpha Q signaling that we're going
to come back to one other thing that I'd
like to note here is this is a different
view on those same drug impacted
pathways that the drug binding can
actually have a very different impact on
the pathway so the size of the circle
here is indicating the number of drugs
that impact that pathway and if you look
at the top our friend G alpha Q
signaling has three drugs that interact
with it and they all have a very similar
effect a very high impact but if you
look at Red's ret signaling which is the
first red circle from the top so what
the bars are showing you is the drug
that had the minimum impact and the drug
that had the maximum impact and so we
can see there's a very wide range in the
drugs interacting with ret signaling
there's actually 20 different drugs
interacting with this pathway but the
degree of impact that they have looks to
be very different from the modeling okay
so I'd like to provide some discussion
on how we might begin to unite these two
modeling approaches because that's
really the vision of where we'd like to
go is how can we use individual patient
level mutation information and figure
out the best drug for that patient so
this is a version of the blue graph that
we just showed only now instead of the
dots being blue I've actually colored
them to indicate whether their drug
impacted or not so we're starting to
intersect these two approaches so the
darker red it goes is
more impact that the drug is predicted
to have on the pathway and so now we're
going to come back to our example of G
alpha Q signaling so this pathway has
both a high impact from the mutation and
from the drug perspective so we'd like
to look a little more closely at
examples like this
so there are 12 samples in this group
that have mutations in this pathway and
so what this graph is showing is on the
left it's showing the genes that each
sample had a mutation in each circle on
their graph is one sample and so what we
can see is while there's 12 patients
that all had mutations in this pathway
they all have mutations in very
different genes right so again
highlighting the one of the advantages
of the pathway perspective is bringing
together many of these different genes
interestingly from the modeling all
these genes were predicted to have a
very high impact on this pathway and so
if we look from the drug perspective now
there's three drugs interacting with
this pathway that also have a very high
impact so Fortezza meb is in red idelle
Elizab is in green and Serafina is in
blue and now from this perspective it's
showing the targets in the pathway that
the drug interacts with so given that we
see that this pathway both has a high
mutation impact in individual patients
and also potentially high impact from
drug we'd start to like to look and see
if there's actually a difference in drug
responses for these patients so just as
one quick example
so this is showing the distribution of
the drug response force or a phanom so
one of the drugs that I pointed out to
you so each sample here is shown as a
dot and if that Sam if that patient has
a mutation in the pathway that we've
been discussing it's colored and we can
see the gene
listed on the right here and so we can
see that three of these patients who
have a very very low AUC or more
responsive to more sensitive to the drug
I should say do have mutations in this
pathway so this is and then I'll show
one other way to look at this and so now
we're actually looking at it by each
sample so each sample is one pane and
we're seeing their response to the three
different drugs that the modeling shows
interact with this pathway and you can
see that several samples have surrounded
the blue very low that's who we saw on
the other plot the idle afib in green
and then fortezza mabh in red and so
this is just one way of showing how we
might unite these two frameworks to
really start to think about bringing
together the mutation and the drug
impacted
there's definitely much more work to be
done in this vein this is the start so
for instance going in more to seeing
what other gene mutations that these
samples have in other pathways because
right now we're looking at just the G
alpha Q signaling but this starts to
show how we can use the modeling
framework to potentially prioritize
pathways a very high interest for our
samples so in working towards a unified
model of both mutation and drug
perturbation we've identified some key
areas definitely for the next iterations
so the first is curation of pathways so
I've been talking a lot about these
biochemical pathways and coming from
react dome a really key piece of the
type of modeling that we're doing this
impact modeling relies on those pathways
being very well connected so what I'm
showing here in the left corner is some
entities in a pathway have dashed lines
right and then we also have one that's
actually separate so in pathways where
we see something like this where the
connections are incomplete it's very
difficult for us to model impact because
we're not going to be able to propagate
fully
as a second needed component is the
stability of pathways so I haven't gone
into this very much in today's talk but
I will just mention that that message
passing that I showed you is not
necessarily guaranteed to find a final
result or guaranteed to converge
especially in the case of pathways with
a high number of loops we found that it
might not be possible to get to those
Boies and so that's definitely something
to keep in mind going forward and then
as we move more towards understanding or
towards using this modeling work with
drug sensitivity one thing we definitely
have to keep in mind is the number of
samples that have drug data so we may
find subgroups of patients with impacted
pathways but as you saw from our example
with 12 samples it gets very small very
fast in the number of samples that we
have drug data and impacted pathways and
so we need to keep that in mind when we
think about going forward with potential
pathways of interest okay so in the
first aim we introduced the cancer
target ohm as a way to capture this
uncertainty and drug target information
and really get our hands on drug target
data future work that I'd love to see
for cancer target ohm is moving to all
fda-approved drugs and also including
investigational compounds because right
now it's just for cancer drugs and we
really like to widen our scope there's
definitely a more work that could be
done for the level two content so that's
where we retrieved an interaction and it
has a reference but there's could be
some questions about where did what is
in that reference and why wasn't a
binding assay value reported level three
metadata so additional annotation
thinking about the cell lines that were
tested for that drug target interaction
experimental conditions we'd really like
to have that information to assist in
further prioritization of drug target
information so we also talked about how
the cancer target ohm enables us to
estimate cancer druggable space
this idea of the light and the dark
pathways and so this is really exciting
to me as potentially for repurposing
especially if we have information from
drugs and non-cancer domains we could
potentially bring them in in cancer uses
and we looked at how the pathway
perspective actually allows us to
capture associations between drug
response and a pathway that very
promising lis look to go beyond just
single gene and drug interactions and
this could potentially take us forward
for stratifying patients into different
subgroups and then we talked about the
modeling framework for assessing both
mutational and drug impact and really
working to uniting those two arms of
this framework because we'd like to be
able to model patient mutational data
and the drug combined to figure out what
drug will be best for that patient the
modeling framework has a lot of
advantages and there's a lot of ways we
could take that going forward there's
definitely room for incorporating
additional gene or drug target
information such as the location of the
mutation in the gene and then something
definitely to think about for this
modelling is that the modeling that I
have done so far treats each pathway
separately but we know that these
pathways actually talk to each other so
crosstalk so thinking about how to take
that into consideration as well so with
that I would like to acknowledge my
dissertation Advisory Committee so dr.
McWeeny
dr. woo dr. Cohen dr. brought and dr.
Tyner then it's very important to
acknowledge my funding for my PhD has
come from the National Library of
Medicine informatics training grant
which was really an incredible
opportunity and the beat animal
consortium also a wonderful opportunity
to work with the researchers and work
with patient data and so I also have to
think the patience for the donation of
their samples for this for this work the
head and neck squamous cell carcinoma
group so that's dr. McQueen and dr.
coulis Martin's grew
I've been doing work with them
throughout my time here thank you to
demise for being my home during my time
here faculty staff and fellows and some
special thanks to dr. Dion chase and dr.
Ted ladarius especially for early on in
my program they provide a lot of support
gabriele to new and then also dr. Hannah
Highlander who was my mentor in
undergraduate and sent me on the path
for mathematical modeling a long time
ago and then of course thank you to my
partner
Siegen and all my family so open
yeah thank you yes oh okay so that
that's a good question so so first yes
all the binding assay information is
actually from experimental tests so just
for the audience so Dion's also
referencing that a lot of these
databases will have predicted binding
affinities as well for drug target
interactions we're not using those and
the model doesn't actually we're not
predicting any strengths of new drug
target binding so that I would say would
be a future direction to go to because
we could see impact and then see it
could be a way of providing more
validation for predicted drug target
interactions yeah
[Music]
how strong is your pathway analysis to
look at those two
so I definitely think that this modeling
could be done in multiple time points so
if if we had the mutation data from
multiple time points then we could for
instance get a snapshot of the pathway
impacts at different stages I think it
could be adopted for that did you have
another question okay
but the the interactions are not
necessarily beneficial or detrimental
and so is there a way to model that
because it seems that that might in
terms of its usefulness and identifying
those drugs that could be repurposed so
thinking about like which and really
thinking about beneficial targets it
really depends on the purpose and what
we're trying to use them for but I think
you're also getting out thinking about
which targets and pathways might be
leading to side effects or adverse
effects as well as that okay so yeah
thinking about how we could prioritize
not just for the pathways we want to hit
but also if we want to avoid and then
potentially a future direction would be
to be very strategic with the modeling
for combinations of therapies especially
for tackling resistance
Mitzi Thanks
yeah sure
[Music]
I could you like this one yes
[Music]
oh yeah
we related
yeah so thank you for asking that
question because for this talk it was a
little bit under the hood for that so
basically for cancer target only have
these binding si values so they're
reflecting the strength of the
interaction between the drug and the
target and then we're actually using
those directly in our graph so remember
I told you that each entity can be in
the 0 or the 1 state we're actually
converting that to model the impact so
if x1 is a drug target and it has a very
very high or very strong binding assay
value then we're pushing that to be with
very high probability in the one state
and so there's actually a conversion
that I didn't show here where we're
actually taking the binding assay values
and coding them into the impact on those
nodes thank you
any other questions okay well thank you
all so much
oh yeah
[Music]